[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the villains of
boku no hero and why I think that the
villains play an absolutely crucial role
in the story
if boku no hero focused mostly on the
lives of high-school students who are
trying to become pro heroes but never
had to face off against the real
villains the story would be completely
different and while I know that a lot of
you guys really like the tournament art
from season two and other school
centered arcs I personally always loved
the villain centric arcs the most and in
this video I will explain why and what
better time to talk about the importance
and the appeal of the villains now that
we are learning more and more about the
different villains and what drives them
what motivates them to do what they do
and to be who they are
last week on Twitter and Instagram I
asked you guys to come up with your own
unique ideas for a new villain in the
world of boku no hero including their
own villain named backstory and unique
quirk and I got a ton of Awesome
responses so I will be reading some of
those at the end of this video for next
week I want to make a video about Minoru
Mineta but I need your help to decide
what exactly to talk about in that video
so be sure to head over to our Twitter
and Instagram at anime uproar and give
me your suggestions on what I should
talk about both serious suggestions and
memes are welcome and my favorite
suggestions will be featured in that
video if you enjoyed the MHA content on
this channel be sure to leave a like to
let me know and if you happen to be new
don't forget to subscribe and Detroit
smash that notification bell now the big
reason why I think that the villains are
so crucial for the story of boku no hero
is that through their diverse
backgrounds and beliefs they represent
the different aspects of the world of
boku no hero and they serve as a
critique of the hero society one thing
you will notice right away is that the
villains in boku no hero are all very
different they have different
backstories different ideologies and
different motivations for example in
season three of the anime we meet a
whole bunch of new villains including
muscular
muscular is a villain who just enjoys
fighting and killing he is just a
violent guy and even though he is part
of the vanguard action squad when he is
asked what the plans of the villains are
he says that he doesn't even care he
just loves fighting
similarly Magni is a brutal murderer
accused of dozens of violent crimes who
joined the villain action squad just for
the freedom that comes with being a
member of a powerful villain group
because of course if you have a strong
team of villains around you then you
could commit crimes and do whatever you
like without worrying about getting
arrested so on the one hand we have
villains like this we're just violent by
nature just bad people who want to do
bad things but on the other hand we have
villains like Staind who are driven by a
clear ideology Stane wants to expose
false heroes who became pro heroes for
their own selfish interests and not to
actually help others and make the world
a better place
stain is such a powerful and influential
presence as a villain that he actually
inspires a bunch of other villains to
follow in his footsteps including people
like dobby spinner and toga although
toga is also a pretty disturbed yandere
so although she is inspired by stains
she takes it in a whole different
bloodthirsty direction and then we have
villains like shigaraki he doesn't start
out with any clear ideology his own
tragic backstory drove him to hate the
hero society and all might as the symbol
of peace but I don't want to get into it
too much because I don't want to spoil
it for you guys who haven't read the
manga as the manga goes on we learn
about all sorts of different villains
including villains whose goal is to make
a fortune by controlling the criminal
underworld villains who want to
weaponize quirks to take over entire
countries and perhaps even the world and
villains who don't care about money and
power as much as they do about Fame they
want to be immortalized by becoming the
world's most famous criminals this
diversity of villains in boku no hero
reflects the diversity of criminals in
the real world some criminals just want
money
others are violent and want to hurt
others some just want fame and others
have political and ideological
motivations they want to fight against
what they perceive as the in Justices of
society so in this sense the
of boku no hero are appealing to us
because they are not all just evil for
the sake of being evil and they're not
all the same we can see how the villains
in boku no hero paralleled the criminals
in our own world and we can imagine that
if we lived in a world with quirks these
types of villains might really appear
it's not that far-fetched in some cases
like with stain we can even sympathize
with some of the things that he believes
it there are plenty of people in our own
world who use money power and fame just
for their own selfish interests and not
to help others so we can kind of
understand how stain would be outraged
by what he sees as false heroes
exploiting society for their own
advantage the villains are so important
to the story because we first entered
the world of boku no hero through the
eyes of Deku someone who loves and
idolizes Pro Heroes foredeck who the
hero society is an amazing thing and he
desperately wants to become a part of it
so he isn't thinking about the negative
consequences dec who doesn't think
critically about turning the act of
being a hero into a lucrative job
instead of a sincere calling he doesn't
necessarily think about the dark side of
the hero society however through
villains like stain and shigaraki and
through other characters like coda we
get to explore the dark side of this
society when you turn being a hero into
a job that comes with money and fame you
are definitely going to have some people
becoming heroes for the wrong reasons
just look at the flame hero endeavor and
how he is considered to be one of the
top heroes in the world and he is
praised for helping people despite the
fact that he is actually a terrible
person who abuses his own family who is
going to protect endeavors family from
him when he has so much power and
influence as a pro hero and when you
have a society that is based on the idea
that the heroes are there to save
everyone and that all might is the
symbol of peace who will protect
everyone at all costs then we run into a
problem because we know that in reality
it is impossible to protect every
and then those people who were not
protected those who were in some way
neglected or rejected by the hero
society will feel alienated and they
will rebel against it
not to mention quirks quirks are
extremely cool and powerful and we love
to talk about them and compare them to
each other to see which one is stronger
but we have to remember that powerful
quirks can be possessed by terrible
people
if heroes have strong quirks that means
that criminals will have them too and
just because you have an epic quirk and
you sometimes use it to help others
doesn't mean that you're truly a good
person on the inside as we can see with
endeavor a world with quirks isn't going
to be just noble heroes protecting the
innocent and having a great time
a world with quirks is a world with a
lot of dangerous people walking around
and a lot of disasters just waiting to
happen
this is the site of boku no hero that we
would never get to understand without
the villains if we only saw the world
through the idealistic lens of someone
like Deku someone who still doesn't
understand the dark side of humanity
then boku no hero would not have been
nearly as good of a story so the
villains and boku no hero are appealing
for a number of reasons let's be honest
many of them are just cool and have cool
quirks but beyond that they're also very
diverse and it is interesting to compare
all their different backstories and
motivations and most importantly these
diverse and interesting villains make
boku no hero a better story
they make us question the pro hero
society they make us see the potential
downside of a world full of people with
superpowers and so they make the story
of boku no hero more than just a
one-dimensional tale about good guy
heroes defeating generic bad guys who
are just bad for the sake of being bad
I've said it before and I'll say it
again the villains are in many ways the
backbone of the boku no hero's story the
author horikoshi is aware of this as
well and the way that someone like
shigaraki develops as a character
throughout the story in many ways
parallels decos own development
the main protagonist and the good guys
are not the only ones changing evolving
getting smarter and getting stronger
shigaraki and the villains are doing it
too and this is exactly what makes for
such a compelling adventure that has the
potential to go on for a long time both
in manga and anime form this isn't just
a cliche struggle between good and evil
it's a struggle between different
ideologies different philosophies
different life experiences and different
ways of light and that is what I love
about this story let me know what you
guys think do you like the villains in
boku no hero and do you agree with me
that the villains play a crucial role in
making this series what it is and by the
way who is your favorite out of all of
the villains let me know down in the
comments and now for your ideas on
Twitter and Instagram about a brand new
villain in the world of boku no hero I
want to thank everyone who participated
I read all of your responses and I
really liked them I will say though that
some of the responses were really really
long so while I did read them I couldn't
include them all in this video and in
some cases I had to summarize all of the
responses are still available on Twitter
and Instagram if you guys want to go and
check them out but this video would take
all day if I try to include them all
first up on Twitter Mari actually drew
my friend and fellow and a tuber knocks
Taku as a boku no hero villain in last
week's video I suggested the idea that
knocks Taku is an anime villain and
clearly that idea was accepted
wholeheartedly by you guys including by
NOx Taku himself great work with this
one Mari next up we have max VDT and he
created a villain who is also named max
VDT this person stole a prototype helmet
from genius inventor Mei hot zoomin and
with the help of this helmet this person
can use their imagination to create
anything they imagined but it would only
last for five hours right off the bat I
like the idea of stealing something from
Mei because we know that she's a genius
inventor so I'm curious about all the
different things that she could invent
and how those things would work together
in combination with quirks we definitely
need to see more of Mei in this story
and I think this villain and their quirk
would be extremely powerful I mean just
imagine
able to create anything I mean think
about it you could even bring your own
waifu to life at least for five hours
Josefa ralph proposes a villain named
hydra the backstory of this villain is
that their parents got killed by debris
during a fight between all might and
another villain their quirk is the
ability to manipulate water and if they
get angry the water will begin to boil
however the weakness of this work is
that the user will become dehydrated if
they use it too much I really like this
concept of innocent people being killed
by accident as a result of all might
fighting a villain
obviously all might would never hurt an
innocent person on purpose but when
you're having a battle and using a lot
of power in a populated area there is
bound to be some collateral damage and a
villain who was created because of
something like this would again be a
great way to bring out the dark side of
the pro hero society tarik McMaster
names his villain Quantum this villain
was hated as a child because he abused
his quirk now he wants others to feel
that hatred the name Wes work is time
mastery and he can control time on a
whim but he has to use it sparingly
because whenever he uses that he loses
one week off of his lifespan I've always
been a fan of time-based powers and I
like the concept of losing some of your
lifespan whenever you use the quirk
because it would force the villain to
use it only in important situations this
is a quirk that would definitely be very
old P unless it had a major limitation
and of course losing some of your
lifespan I think counts as a major
limitation Ethan Rankin created a
villain called casino the name of their
quirk is luck of the draw and casino can
copy a random quirk he knows of that
he's seen before I assume but he cannot
select which work he will get and all
the effects of this quirk will last for
one hour he joined the League of
villains hoping to learn about more
quirks that he could potentially copy
and he also wanted to learn about all
night and what his quirk is I actually
loved this idea of being able to copy a
quirk but not being able to control
which quirk you get to use that would
make for some awesome scenes where the
villain doesn't know what quirk he just
got so he has to figure it out on the
spot I also see a lot of potential for
humor in this and a
like this would really force the user to
adapt quickly I really like this idea
Jeremy Breslin wants to see a villain
who spent most of his life homeless
because his parents disapproved of him
being someone with a quirk and because
of this he concluded that parents drag
their children down emotionally
as for the quirk it is an impact builder
where each hit is stronger the more hits
you land so basically the bigger your
combo of hits the stronger each
subsequent hit becomes again really cool
concept I don't think we've seen this in
boku no hero yet but even though most
people have quirks there are still a lot
of people who don't so maybe the parents
of this villain are some sort of Puritan
religious people who think that anyone
with a quirk is a terrible mutant a
deviant and so on that would definitely
bring another angle into the world of
boku no hero and I also like this idea
for a quirk it reminds me of derriere
ease power combo star from the seven
deadly sins
and I would definitely want to see a
villain like this in action
nice job Jeremy over on Instagram we
have you seen moose aide who wants a
villain with that same name the name of
the villain would be clay man and his
quirk would be mud this quirk allows the
user to transform their body or parts of
their body into mud but when they use it
and the longer they stay in the form the
slower they become the quirk of course
allows the user to capture and trap
other people using the mud this quirk
reminds me of a logia Devil food from
one piece and I can definitely see it
being used to great effect in boku no
hero later in the manga we meet a pro
hero who can turn parts of his body into
sand so this idea is definitely not far
from what's possible also on instagram
we have comped Hobbit they propose a
villain called shedinja whose quirk
would be umbrella manipulation this
quirk allows the user to make up to 20
shadow like replicates of themselves
which accurately mimic their moves he
can also switch positions with one of
his shadow clones instantly but the
shadow clones cannot hurt anyone and if
the lighting is too bright the shadow
clones will not be able to appear as for
the backstory this villain was the son
of a pro hero who died during a mission
because a fellow hero chose to save his
own life instead of helping his friend
this caused shedinja to become
disillusioned with the world
pro heroes and turn to the world of
crime this quirk reminds me of the clone
technique in Naruto especially because
the clones don't have the ability to
hurt someone directly but if the user of
this quirk has extra weapons like stain
does then this could still be a very
useful quirk since you can use the
clones - totally distract and confuse
your opponent and then you move in and
take them out anyway great ideas guys
really awesome suggestions thank you all
so much don't forget to follow us on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar so
you can contribute to future videos
including the next video on Minoru
minute ah if you enjoyed these videos I
want to see more be sure to leave a like
to let me know and of course if you're
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and Detroit smash that
notification bell as always thank you
all so much for watching and until next
time see our space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]